hi and welcome to the course this course
will be the first of series of courses
where you will learn to build great
products we thought a lot about whether
entrepreneurship can be taught and there
are many courses in reference materials
out there but we wondered whether that
material or series of courses can really
transform someone into an entrepreneur
someone that is an unconventional hacker
a risk taker and a jack-of-all-trades
successful entrepreneurship is a lot
more than the inner workings of a
company or the character of the founders
it involves a number of external factors
which make it extremely difficult to
have a single formula for success every
moment in history
will only happen once there would be
only one air B&B there won't be any
other Google fortunately there are
plenty of other problems too left for
you to solve yeah and this course is
designed to teach you some best
practices and processes that Silicon
Valley companies have developed over the
past few years on how to create
beautiful and meaningful products we
hope you can use them as a framework to
build a business of your own
because startups are risky and costly
business it is always wise to validate
early on build only what you need and
not more and iterate as fast as you can
throughout this course we'll talk to
several startups who have done just that
let's hear from them now